I have some news that might be shocking
to a lot of people in our audience if I
say the number 97% and climate change a
lot of people in our audience know that
that refers to the supposed consensus in
our scientific community that human
actions on our planet are causing
climate change and this is a number
that's very often cited we have a ton of
science around this number we have a ton
of studies that defend this number
there's 97% consensus and I have what
might be very very surprising news for
many people in our audience today which
is that I'm ready to come clean and
admit that the 97% number is flawed it's
just it's not an accurate number I don't
want to call it fake news because that's
giving them a win on the language which
I don't want to do but it's in an
incorrect number and if you're a climate
science denier and you're starting to
feel aroused and titillated by what I'm
saying I want to encourage you to keep
your clothes on just for a second
because it's not that 97% is too high it
actually is drastically low it appears
that the real consensus over recent
history on human influence of our
climate is 99.94% not 97% and this is
based on a new meta-analysis that looked
at more than 50,000 peer-reviewed
climate change articles from 91 to 2015
and it's not 97% consensus it's 99.94%
and even that number might be too low
because if you look at not 91 to 2015
but just like the last few years it
appears to be 99.99 percent consensus
that human activities on our planet are
influencing the climate and one of the
major problems is that belief in the
science is extremely politicized and if
you look at a recent Gallup survey which
asked people basically three questions
are you worried about climate change do
you know that there's a scientific
consensus and do you believe that humans
are causing it Democrats overwhelmingly
believe that those three things are true
right 85 to 90 percent of Democrats are
worried they believe that there is a
scientific consensus and they believe
that humans are in
wincing the climate on the other hand
only 35 to 42 percent of Republicans are
either aware of or concerned about or
believe that humans are influencing the
climate so this gets us to what I call
informational incongruity
okay I've talked about this before you
this this is something that the audience
seems to react very positively to
because it identifies what I think is a
major problem level one is like we know
about an issue we agree that it's an
important issue but we just disagree on
our position is different right so like
abortion abortion is a political issue
we could debate whether it's resolved or
not based on roe v wade but we have
significant disagreement about what the
policy should be on abortion a level ii
disagreement would be we generally know
about the issue but do we disagree how
important it is so like before same-sex
marriage went national as a result of
the Supreme Court decision most people
were aware of the controversy over
same-sex marriage but some people just
didn't really care about it as an issue
they didn't think it was anything we
needed to deal with like listen it's
just not legal in some places and that's
good and I don't care about that level
three is a lot of people don't know
about the issue level three
informational incongruity that's like
Fox News viewers who might have no idea
that there's a major investigation into
what took place between Trump and Russia
we can't even debate the merits of it
we can't even debate the importance of
it because some people aren't even aware
that it is going on and on climate
change that's kind of the direction that
things are going you don't even have a
majority of Republicans realizing that a
scientific consensus exists so number
one I don't think anyone's gonna be
influenced because the real number is
ninety-nine point nine four versus
ninety seven because if you already
trusted the 97% number you're not going
to change your position because it's now
ninety-nine point nine four and if you
weren't aware of that number or believed
that it's fake anyway
you also don't care if it goes from 97
to 99 so I actually don't know how we
can really get beyond this and start
figuring out what to do about the
climate science issue but the numbers
are stunning and at this point
completely undeniable and I'm curious
whether you've experienced these sort of
Sciences your religion people there's
people who will write in to me I'll say
David
you're touting science in a faith-based
way the same way that people tell
religion and I have to explain to people
well hold on a second
science has built-in self correction
mechanisms and in fact in science people
are encouraged there are major rewards
for people who can poke holes in what
are the accepted scientific consensus
consensus consensuses I don't know what
the plural is you can win a Nobel Prize
if you debunk the consensus on science
where do you see that in religion you
just don't you just don't but I think
the religion connection is actually
closer to politics because there are
people doing politics as religion and I
think it's bleeding into science because
what you find is like you said there's
die-hard Republicans that as part of
their Republican identity sure are
saying that this science is just it's
bunk it's all a a green conspiracy
that's a political religion it really
has nothing to do with the science the
thing that gives me a lot of hope is
that when you look at the presidential
elections when you talk about hardcore
Republicans year after year after year
it's about 25 percent of us so most of
us don't fall into that category
seventy-five percent of us either look
at this consensus and go like yeah it's
real or the other people in the middle
that either don't know don't care
a lot of people it's not really about
climate science so one of the things
that I do on my show is because that's
controversial I talk more about the
pollution because the solution is the
same job burning fossil fuels yep so
there's ways for us to get to solutions
without having to deal with the
political religions I think one of them
is just taking the 25 percent and be
like you're religious about this we
can't really talk I prefer to talk to
the 50 percent that aren't voting that
are in the middle that just don't know
what to do with this whole situation and
then the people that are already sold
the vast majority of it yeah that is
something I talk about which is you
actually don't need to convince the
outliers and the extremists in order to
win elections because we have 50% voter
turnout in this country and president
Trump conceivably could win reelection
based on a combination of low voter
turnout and our electoral vote system
with an approval in there in the 20s
right in the high 20s you can actually
still win a presidential election
because people don't vote if the
shoutout to George W Bush yeah if the
voter turnout went even just from
roughly 50 to even something like 62
percent you completely marginalize the
ability of those extremists who have
these related and the religions go
beyond the sort of political religion I
think is an interesting term because you
see those dogmatic beliefs around
constitutionalism and constitutional
originalism the idea of the Constitution
effectively as a sacred text similar to
the Bible or the Koran or whatever else
you see it with this what I call strict
father morality strict father morality
is the dogmatic idea that I claim to
want to reduce abortion if I am a right
winger and then someone comes to me and
says we know how to do it comprehensive
sex education and ready access to
contraceptives I'm against that if I'm a
right-wing conservative because you are
not actually behaving in the correct way
if you have unprotected I'm sorry
protected sex non-procreative sex you
deserve the consequences almost like a
strict father saying if you do it you
should get pregnant and you should be
forced to carry the baby to a full term
and give birth to it that is a dogmatic
idea fundamentally it's not a pragmatic
idea where we actually know what works
to reduce the number of abortions right
and I think it applies even beyond
climate change there's a lot of these
pseudo religious dogmatic ideas the
other one is the free market right that
exists on the right this this sort of
religious approach to the free market we
uh I don't actually think that just
because we agree to the consensus
doesn't guarantee what the policy should
be and I think that that scares some
people on the right
certainly the reduction in fossil fuel
use is sort of an obvious one but I
think that there's just a lot of people
on the right who are scared to admit
that they are aware of the consensus or
just agree with the consensus because
they believe that it definitely means I
don't know no more SUVs or whatever it
is but there's still a debate to be had
over what the policy should be although
I think as you pointed out the direction
that the policy should go is pretty
obvious at this point it is and I
actually I I don't even agree
necessarily the people on the right are
against reducing fossil fuels not
because of all yeah because when you
actually talk to people I mean there are
plenty of conservative
reasons why you should switch to
renewable energy absolutely you know
there's people that are for wind in fact
um I'm researching electric cars right
now and one of the people that is
rumored to have saved the tax credits is
Senator Chuck Grassley of Iowa yeah and
you can't get more Republican than him
but he's into wind energy and the
economics of it makes sense sure so I
don't think it's necessarily and just
out in the world there are plenty of
people that I know that are Republicans
but are driving electric cars that do
care about this that know the science
but that's that's one of the problems I
have with just like dividing people in
the left and right because my own father
he's me so annoying that I talk about
him but my own dad was a Republican on
when I was growing up he counts himself
as a libertarian now he drives an
electric car he is singing the praises
of it he volunteered at an aquarium for
years you know he's really into
environmentalism people just don't
really fit very well into these boxes
and when it comes to fossil fuels what
I'm witnessing is that our Congress
which makes the laws is far more extreme
yeah then most of the country on most
issues that's true and that else has a
lot to do with the broader issues of how
politics are financed and a lot of other
stuff yeah totally the video you just
watched was made possible by support
from you please go to patreon.com slash
david pakman show you can make a pledge
of as little as $1 per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad